we are living in uncertain times
political unrest violence famine disease
but there's one problem that is sweeping
the world this is a problem in the
States but it's very much a problem in
Japan Sweden Denmark and that's an issue
that I know is very close to Michael's
heart very close Millennials aren't
[ __ ]
[Music]
I feel like sex is the one thing we
shouldn't have to sell to people Michael
che is always asking me why are
Millennials having more sex
yeah except he says teens instead of
Millennials yeah why not why is it that
people aren't having sex Nicholas I
think it's because we have the world in
our pocket now you can just do this
instead of looking at someone like this
which doesn't allow them to pick up on
the musk of the opposite sex I love
video games my only problem with video
games is that while I'm playing video
games I'm not having sex people are too
focused on this weird alternate reality
and not the face-to-face beautiful human
connections that we all make them take
my hand from this part but also you got
to remember kids you don't gotta have
sex face to face
stop usually apps it makes it too easy
and it makes you feel like you're too
good you seamless though that's Matt fat
you seamless when you get her over at
your house boy or the tacos pretend you
cook them yes now she's in the mood
looking for jobs that's a big reason
people aren't having sex because they're
like looking for a good job you know
what the best job is [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] then like being a CEO
that's like third best kind of job you
can have the person with the best job in
the world like the CEO still has the
third best kind of job possible there's
other pieces Millennials aren't having
sex maybe you don't have enough space in
your room having a Twitter that's
popping trying to cross the street and
not get hit by a bus because you have no
health insurance yes sex is gross mm-hmm
agree to disagree I have not had sex
well that very reason I've gotten close
not that close not down here you know
how you solve this problem you should
try having sex go away yeah and you tape
it and usually you send these tapes all
around the world two men would push bro
mustaches and members
only jackets I like it with some people
you know what nobody ever does nobody
ever goes man I really regret having
that sex actually have sex with people
that you might not want to have sex with
initially I don't want to overstate this
but as a millennial having sex you will
be this generation is Rosa Parks guys
try to get out there and grab some
poontang cuz it really is a beautiful
thing you'll find out one day it really
is one of the most glorious things that
can be shared between two human beings
sounds awesome
[Music]
that was horrible that made me not want
to have sex my boner into the ground
yeah really me mm-hmm GQ [ __ ] me